we are delighted to bring you this
seminar presented by lab roots
welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's kino presentation
titled systematic identification of
therapeutic strategies
that leverage tumor evolution
it's my pleasure to introduce you to dr
chris wood
assistant professor department of
pharmacology and cancer biology
duke university dr chris wood received
his phd in chemical
engineering from the massachusetts
institute of technology where he
developed
self-assembling polymeric systems for
controlled gene and drug delivery
his work focused on the development of
functional genomic tools to study the
determinants
of anti-cancer drug sensitivity
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the question and answer box
and our speaker will respond back to you
via email
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
please join me in welcoming dr wood
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
well i my name is chris wood i'm from
the department of pharmacology and
cancer biology at duke university
uh and i first want to start off just by
saying a thank you to the organizers of
this event
for the invitation to speak today on
some of the work that that we're doing
and that we're excited about that
involves
the use of systematic approaches to
identify
anti-cancer therapeutic strategies that
we um
think have the opportunity provide us
with an opportunity to
shape the way the tumors evolve
so my laboratory actually works in in
two areas um one of the things that we
work on
uh is the in the space of novel tumor
vulnerability so we've done a lot of
work in recent years
to try to understand novel ways of
therapeutically targeting
tumors particularly tumors that are have
been historically refractory to
precision therapies
many of these studies have over time
have centered on
the mitochondria this organelle in
cancer cells that
as you all know i'm sure integrates
upstream signals from the cancer cell's
environment and from
aberrantly activated oncogenic pathways
and transduces those signals in a number
of important ways
and one way that's particularly
interesting to us in my group
is the the fact that those signals are
transduced to
uh to regulate the bcl-2 family proteins
which are these
um a family of pro and antibiotic
proteins that
exist within and around the mitochondria
and uh
these proteins through a sort of um a
physical interac a series of
physical interactions uh dictate a
cell's decision to
live or die as well as other things like
a decision to trigger
inflammatory processes and so we've been
very interested in understanding
how we can interfere
with the upstream signals that feed into
the mitochondria and by doing so
alter the state of the bcl-2 family
proteins to drive therapeutic effects
and tumors
the second area that my lab works in is
in the in the field of tumor evolution
and particularly evolution in the face
of therapeutic
uh selection pressures so drug
resistance evolution
and our work in this space has fallen
into kind of two areas
on one hand we're very interested in
using systematic approaches to try to
map
this the landscape of signaling pathways
that can drive resistance to therapy
uh and in the other hand we're also very
interested in taking insights that we
glean
from those studies and using them to to
define
mechanism-based therapies that the
potential to overcome or
potentially even circumvent uh the
development of resistance
so for the rest of my talk today i'm
actually going to focus on the work that
we do just in the secondary of my lab
and hopefully
and in a future time i'll be able to
talk more about our area in
our work in the area of tumor
vulnerabilities so
our lab started our work in resistance
in 2012 at the time
when i was actually starting my
independent lab here at duke
um and at that time our um our thinking
about resistance
was um in retrospect quite simplistic uh
and i think in some ways our simplistic
thinking was reflective of the the field
the broader fields
relatively simplistic approach to the
problem of resistance
the way that we were thinking about
resistance in 2012 was that
if you can define the pathways of
resistance
then you can overcome that resistance um
to put it differently
we had the idea that when a patient
would be treated with an anti-cancer
drug they would initially respond and
then when they stopped responding
we envisioned a scenario where a patient
would be able to go to their physician
their tumor could be biopsied in one of
a number of ways
and that using genomic approaches we
could define or or um
credential the operative resistance
mechanism that was at play in that
patient's body
and that uh by then matching that
knowledge of that resistance mechanism
to a drug that blocks that mechanism
we could overcome resistance um and so
with that
simplistic idea in mind uh in our view
was that the real key to the field was
figuring out ways of discovering
resistance pathways at scale because
while we knew a lot about resistance
to a small number of drugs things like
egfr inhibitors used in
lung cancer or b rap inhibitors used in
melanoma
we actually knew relatively little about
mechanisms of resistance to many many
other types of drugs
now to discover resistance pathways at
scale
we have developed and adapted a number
of functional genomic technologies
we have notably created pathway-focused
libraries of cdnas or
crispr reagents which can be introduced
into cell cells
and upon introduction lead to the
constitutive
activation or inactivation of defined
oncogenic pathways
now the reason why we choose oncogenic
pathways to focus on
is that we reason that the pathways that
drive
tumor cell growth and survival and
[Music]
differentiation and repair processes for
example
might also likely be the same processes
that tumor cells would often exploit to
become resistant to therapy
now after developing and extensively
validating those reagents
the the notion that we had in our mind
was that we could take them we could
introduce them as a pool
into cancer cells in a dish or or an
animal
and we could then separate those cells
each one
constitutively expressing an activator
or enacted vader of a defined oncogenic
pathway
and we can split those cells into two
identical groups one of which would be
treated with a drug and the other which
would be true with the vehicle
the idea is that over time we would
expect that the oncogenic pathways that
when activated give a preferential
survival in the presence of a drug would
become enriched in the drug-treated
population
and that we could identify those
enrichments through through
next-generation sequencing based
deconvolution and on the
um on the on the right-hand side of this
slide what you'll see is an example of a
plot that comes out of a study like this
where
on the x-axis we have enumerated
oncogenic pathway activators
and on the y-axis we are plotting fold
enrichment which is the degree to which
that that particular pathway activator
is found enriched in the presence of a
drug
relative to the absence of a drug
now um we we did some initial studies to
prove to ourselves that indeed this
these approaches
uh return to us reliable insights about
resistance mechanisms and then we deploy
them at relatively large scale and so
this is just an example
of a summary of some of the first
studies we did in our group in this
space
what you're looking at in this heat map
are a series of rows each one of which
is a different cancer cell line
that's driven by a defined oncogenic
driver so the first set of cell lines
are driven by b
raft those are melanoma cell lines the
second group of cell lines are
pi3 kinase or pic3ca mutation driven
those are breast cancer cell lines
and so on and so forth down down the
plot
the columns in the heat map correspond
to different
signaling pathways which we've
constitutively activated
using cdna-based techniques
and what you can see at a very high
level is that when you screen
different oncogene-driven cancer cell
lines
with with this approach and you treat
those gene driven cell lines with
appropriate targeted therapies targeting
either the driver oncogene
or its downstream pathway what you find
is that there are certain signaling
pathways those indicated with
red and yellow boxes that seem to be
capable of driving resistance
frequently across many different
oncogenic contexts
so one of the biggest ones that shows up
here is the rasmup kinase pathway which
you can see
forms a red and yellow speckled track
all the way down vertically down through
this heat map
uh suggesting that its constitutive
activation can drive resistance to many
different types of oncogene targeted
therapies
in other settings we see oncogenic
pathways that when activated can confer
context specific resistance so for
example
in the upper right you see the notch
pathway or the estrogen receptor alpha
pathway
both of which when constitutively
activated are capable of driving
resistance to
b raph map kinase pathway blockade in
the setting of brp melanoma
but relatively rarely confer resistance
to in other settings
um now using this and related approaches
that involve loss of function we've
learned a number of things that have led
us to to develop
both a greater insight into clinical
mechanisms of of drug resistance
as well as to design mechanism-based
combination therapies that overcome
resistance
so just to give you two examples of that
i'm first here showing
work that we did in a study that was
published a few years ago where we
studied the phenomenon of
intrinsic resistance to jack kinase
inhibitors
which is observed in patients with
myeloproliferative neoplasms
characterized by active by activating
mutations in jack 2.
now what we know is that when jack 2 is
activated that it's a bona fide driver
in these tumors
and yet patients rarely achieve
substantial
tumor tumor clearance or tumor tumor
burden reduction
uh when they're treated with these drugs
and so through a series of pathway
activating screens what we learned is
that
there are three different ways that you
can develop resistance to
kinase inhibition one is through
reactivation of the jack stat signaling
pathway that corroborates
studies of of of other folks who have um
examined this question and then in a in
a set of findings that were um that had
not been reported before we also
discovered
that activation of oncogenic grass and
downstream irk and akt signaling can
also drive really profound resistance to
jack inhibition
now mechanistic follow-up studies taught
us that indeed these pathways function
through convergent phosphorylation of a
single protein bad the pro-hepatic
protein bad
now phosphorylation of bad at one of two
different sites by these upstream
pathways
leads to its um essentially its
inactivation
such that if the pro survival protein b
cell excel is liberated
and allowed to promote survival in these
cells
that suggests that combining a jack
inhibitor with a bcl excel inhibitor
should be sufficient to overcome this
intrinsic resistance and that question
is actually now being tested in clinical
trials
uh inspired in part by our study
a second example of a finding that we've
had it involves peer counties in breast
cancer so in this case
we examined the phenomenon of intrinsic
resistance to
pi3k mtor pathway blockade and pediatric
kinase mutant breast cancers
and what we were able to discover in
this in this example
was that survival is maintained by the
presence again of the same culprit
the pro uh survival protein bclx cell
even in the face of pi3k infra pathway
blockade
what we uncovered in this study was that
when you block the pa three games or
pathway and pick through ca mutant
breast cancers
that through the suppression of cap
dependent translation
you can reduce levels of a second pro
survival protein mcl1
that operates in the bcl-2 family
network but that because of the
redundant role of b-cell x-cell
that's insufficient to cause apoptotic
cell death
however when you combine inhibitors of
this pathway with inhibitors of b-cell
excel
now you can achieve highly synergistic
apoptotic cell death and pediatric
cardiac
and breast cancers and this approach is
also the subject of
of ongoing efforts for clinical
translation
and in addition to these examples we've
also found a number of examples of
acquired resistance mechanisms
that not only seem to be mechanisms that
are capable of driving resistance to
therapy in the laboratory
but that we see as being likely bona
fide at
mechanisms of intrinsic or acquired
resistance
in actual human patients and in
particular in the in the very patients
whose tumors don't show evidence of of
resistance driven by
other well-known pathways suggesting
that these are actually bona fide
drivers of resistance
so in many ways this approach that we've
that we've taken which i uh described as
being simplistic
has been productive for us we've learned
a lot about mechanisms of resistance
and in some cases about strategies for
overcoming resistance but
i think one of the things that we
learned here is over the course of
several years later
um up to say 2018 when we started taking
a different approach to this problem
is that resistance is actually really
complex um
and so one of the things that we learned
in the years between 2012 and 2018
from a lot of wonderful studies by other
investigators in our field
is that um oftentimes the simplistic
idea
that a patient with resistance could go
to their physician and that their
resistance the operating resistance
mechanism in that patient's body could
be diagnosed
unequivocally that that is an incorrect
assumption
and the reason why it's incorrect is
that oftentimes what we now know
through evidence from circulating dna
analysis as well as from
warm autopsy studies and others is that
in a patient with advanced disease when
they develop resistance there oftentimes
is not just
one mechanism of resistance but rather
many many different
co-occurring mechanisms of resistance
um this creates a really difficult
challenge
for for those of us interested in trying
to overcome resistance because it
suggests
that um that in patients uh treating
a single resistance mechanism will be
unlikely to be effective while treating
many resistance mechanisms is likely to
be toxic
and so this requires us to think in
entirely new ways about there is
the problem of resistance and that
thinking has led us
to a number of ideas one of which i'm
going to describe now
it's the idea that we refer to as um
collateral sensitivity
now what is collateral sensitivity well
collateral sensitivity describes the
idea that
as as we all know while oncogene
targeted therapies lead to the selection
of cells that are resistant to that
therapy
which subsequently expand and and and
found a new tumor which is drug
resistant
the collateral sensitivity hypothesis
postulates that perhaps
the the cells that have the phenotype of
being resistant to therapy
might have their own vulnerabilities
reflecting an evolutionary trade-off
that they've made
in exchange for the development of
phenotypic resistance
now if we can identify what those
vulnerabilities are
we may be able to specifically target
resistant cells
and thereby and spare normal cells but
also
drug sensitive cells now the reason why
this is an interesting hypothesis to us
is that to the extent that collateral
sensitivities are real
and to the extent that they are
conserved across different cellular
clones
driven by different resistance
mechanisms it may actually be
possible to identify and drug those
collateral sensitivities
in combination with upfront oncogene
targeted therapies
and in so doing create a combination
therapy that actually selects against
resistance
and here on the right of this slide i
showed three examples of store of
studies
from our lab and others that have
described specific examples of
collateral sensitivities
so in a very recent study that was just
published we sought to try to understand
and exploit the concept of collateral
sensitivity
using a principle from evolutionary
genetics known as antagonistic pliotropy
and our thinking was as follows we said
look when you're
initially diagnosed with cancer you have
a basal population of cancer cells
and when upon treatment with a drug you
reduce the size of that population and
select for the resistant cells
now over time those resistant cells will
repopulate um
a a drug-resistant tumor
and uh but if if we're very if we're
able to judiciously and appropriately
choose a second therapy
that exploits that resistance phenotype
to specifically drive toxicity
then we might be able to specifically
eradicate that population through a
so-called evolutionary trap
now the key to being able to do this is
understanding the relationship
between the genes that drive resistance
to one drug
and those that drive sensitivity to a
second drug so in other words to put it
differently
it's searching it's the ability this
this approach can
can in some cases hinge upon our ability
to say
that when a tumor is driven by resistant
to resistance by a mechanism
a that it will therefore
deterministically also
be sensitized to a second drug because
of the activation of mechanism a
that phenomenon is known as antagonistic
pleiotropy it's been used in the
evolutionary biology literature
frequently to describe scenarios or to
account for scenarios
where genes seem to have both
paradoxical pro and anti-fitness
properties
now the way we chose to go after looking
for antagonistic pleotropy
is using large-scale crispr cas9 screens
we chose to do these screens in the
setting of acute myeloid leukemia
uh a a a a a deadly uh uh
hematological malignancy um that was
particularly interesting to us
because this is a malignancy in which a
number of different
mechanistically distinct therapies are
advancing clinically right now
now the way that we did our study was to
construct a 2390 gene
crispr library where the genes targeted
by this library are a lot of
kind of well-known cancer genes as well
as drug targets
we created a pool of knockout cells by
introduction of the library into cells
and then we treated those cells with
either either one of a set of nine
different clinically advancing anti-aml
therapies
or dmso treatment over time those
treatments allowed us to select
for um crispr guide rnas
uh that are that that give either a
survival advantage or disadvantage in
the presence of each drug
which we could deconvolute using deep
sequencing and then
the result of each individual drug
screen isn't is a uh
is a sort of uh uh inverted s-shaped
plot like we're showing here in the
upper right portion of the bottom of the
slide
and from that plot we can identify genes
that when knocked out confer either
sensitization or
resistance to each individual drug
therapy
so one of the interesting things that
comes from a net from a study like this
is that you can systematically identify
genes that exhibit the property of
antagonistic pleiotropy within this set
of drugs
and that's really depicted here in the
circus plot i'm showing here now this is
a bit of a complex plot so let me
let me step you through it so um i mean
each each piece of the outer ring of
this plot represents a different drug
sensitize
a drug modifier screen that we've
conducted in the presence of the
indicated drug
now on the outermost ring of the plot
we've numbered
the genes that we screened from uh one
being the one that most strongly
sensitizes when knocked out
to 2400 being the one that uh most
strongly confers resistance when knocked
out
um so you can see that in replicate
screens we've colored the sensitizers
red and the resistors
blue you can see that we get very
largely um
agreeing results as far as which genes
converse since to be resistance to each
screen
and so at the level of each individual's
drug modifier screen
there are things that one could could
study you could look at
mechanisms of potential sensitization
and resistance to each individual drug
but for us where the study became more
interesting was when we started looking
across the screens that we performed
looking specifically for cases where a
gene knockout confers both sensitivity
or sensitization to one drug but
resistance to another drug
and those connections are indicated by
the purple lines
that connect one drug to another within
the
circumferential plot
now another way of looking at this data
set is to say
which pairs of drugs of 36 possible
two-body pairs within the set of nine
drugs
exhibit the most versus the least amount
of antagonistic cleotrophy that is
which um which drugs uh
uh share them have the most number of
genes
uh that that confers sensitivity to one
drug
but resistance to the other drug in
which have the least
so if you look at the top of this plot
we see an example of two drugs decided
being a nasocytodene
which work through similar mechanisms of
action and as expected
have very few numbers of ap genes
while having large numbers of
co-sensitizers and co-resistors
and here i'm just showing in the inside
one specific example of a gene cassette
that shows a resistance
and sensitization uh affects the degree
between the two drugs
now if you look at the bottom of this
plot um you see a second example
of two of two drugs one the bromodomain
inhibitor jq1
and the second the cell two inhibitor um
abt-199
or um venetoclax um which
which show very large numbers of ap
genes
and very small numbers of co-sensitizers
and co-resistors
now this this drug pair was particularly
interesting to us
because the fact that there were so many
ap
genes between these two drug modifier
screens suggests that many of the
mechanisms that drive resistance to one
of these drugs
would be expected to drive sensitization
to the other
and our our follow-up inspections on
this drug pair
led us particularly to a cassette of
genes which are showing here in the
in the plot in the bottom right hand of
the of the slide
what we found was a set of genes the
um the the h3k36
die and trimethyl methylases
nsd2 and sd3 which are generally thought
of as being transcriptionally activating
um which which had scored in a direction
that was consistent with the scoring of
a transcription factor cmic
um in particular what we found was that
knockout of these
uh of these genes conferred resistance
to abt-199
and sensitization to jq1 reciprocally
we found that members of the prc2
complex
which deposits h3k27 trimethyl groups
um scored in the exact opposite
direction uh
in that they their knockout conferred um
sensitization to abt-199
but resistance to jq1 so the notion that
these
um that these this set of genes
scored in a um directionally consistent
manner that's consistent with the
general notion of um nsd2 and three
being
activators of transcription and prc2
complex members
being repressors of transcription um
drove our interest in further follow-up
studies
um the the schematic in the upper left
hand of the of the plot here shows you
the basic idea that nsd2 and three which
could be thought
as activating or facilitating the the
pro oncogenic transcriptional activities
of mick
um uh uh when when uh when active confer
resistance to jq1 and sensitization to 1
9 abt-199
and ezh2 and eed which inhibit mixed
transcriptional activity
would be expected to do the opposite now
to test this model the first thing we
did is we went in and we just said okay
let's overexpress our knockdown mick and
see if it really does affect sensitivity
to these two drugs
and we were able to confirm that it does
so if you knock down mick you become
more sensitive to jq1
and more resistant to 199 if you
overexpress mig
the opposite things happen further we
were able to show that
if you knock down innocent two or three
you get the expected effects on both
make expression as well as on synthetic
sensitivity to jq one
and if you knock down e e d or easy h2
you get the opposite effects it leads to
um
activation of make transcription and
sensitization to
abt-199 um
and moreover i'll tell you although it's
not shown here that we also show that
the effects of nfc 2 and 3
and the eed and ezh2 are mediated
through specifically their effects on
mick
now that's a nice parlor trick that we
can modulate this pathway
and and drive resistance to one drug and
sensitivity to another drug
but it's not really translationally
interesting unless nature
itself selects for this axis and so to
test that what we did is we evolved a
set of five different aml cell lines
to resistance to bromo-domain inhibition
with jq1
through long-term stepwise selection
here you can just see that each of these
five evolved resistant lines which are
shown in maroon
are indeed capable of continuing their
growth in the presence of jq1
in stark contrast to their parental cell
and from which they arose
which cease growth in the presence of
jq1
now we were interested in the
observation that not only are these
jq1 evolved resistant cells resistant to
jq1
but in every case they showed evidence
of substantial
upregulation of mick expression at the
protein level
and in two of five cases they also
showed clear evidence of easy h2 loss
um we later went on to show that indeed
in those cases of easy h2 loss
this easy h2 loss is is uh the driver of
mic
up regulation in these cells which is
consistent with the model nominated by
our screens
and importantly we showed that in in
these resistance cells
the activation of mick specifically
leads to the sensitization
to jq1 uh to uh uh to abt-199
okay so what this basically tells us is
that in
in a manner predicted by our screens
that indeed
evolution of aml cell lines to
resistance to jq1
leads to a mic activated phenotype that
at least in some cases is driven by prc2
loss aspected by our screens
and that a necessary consequence of that
make hyperactivation
is sensitization to abt199 the bcl2
inhibitor
and lastly we show that that
synthesization of 199 is indeed
mcdependent so it's not happening as a
as a passenger event it is indeed a a
secondary
uh consequence of of makeup regulation
the resistance cells
so how does this work how is it that
make up regulation in the setting of
bromo-domain inhibition is driving uh
sensitization to bcl-2 inhibition
um well a number of studies ultimately
centered on
some of the most likely culprits mick
drives a bim-dependent apototic priming
that's shown here through a series of
bh3 profiling assays
and um mick hyperactivation in drug
resistant aml cell lines
is associated with upregulation of bim
one of the
key pro-abiotic proteins in the
mitochondria
that the bim upper regulation is not
only present but it's functionally
important so if you knock out bim
you largely reverse the sensitization to
199 that we observed in these mick
high jq1 resistance cells
now to test this further we took a
a more advanced animal model of aml
these are pdx models from from patients
with aml
that have been transplanted into mice
and the first thing we did with these
models
in under the the plot that says jq1
naive is we measured their baseline
sensitivity
to abt-199 which you can see in maroon
but also to two other drugs
s63 845 and the drug that begins with
a133
which are inhibitors of mcl1 and bcl
excel respectively
what you can hopefully appreciate is
that these drugs have
modest um these cells have modest
sensitivity
to these insults but that if you take
the same cells you put them into a mouse
and treat them with jq1 until they
relapse
now you take the cells back out and what
we find is that they indeed
have exhibit increased sensitivity to
abt-199
so the same priming or sensitization
to abt-199 that we observe in in our
crispr screens
and in our evolved resistant cell lines
in vitro we also
see in a pdx model in vivo and that's
also
seen in the in the gi 50 plot that's
shown on the right
now these results suggest that
combination therapies involving jq1
combined with 199
which might be particularly interesting
in the setting of aml
because the resistance to jq1
necessarily creates a scenario
where aml cells become sensitive to 199
and to
test that in a little bit more detail we
did a study
where we examined the effect of the
sequence with which
aml's are treated with these two drugs
and what effect that has
on tumor burden so we took five
different cohorts of mice and we treated
them with vehicle
abc199 alone jq1 alone abt-199
followed by jq1 which is a treatment
sequence that we would not predict
to select for cells that would be
hypersensitive to the second drug
or jq1 followed by 199 which is a
treatment sequence where we would
predict
that resistance to the first drug would
lead to hypersensitivity to the second
drug
now if you do these these experiments
and then you look in the bone marrow of
the mice
what you find is that indeed the the the
the burden
um of uh
of aml cells in the bone marrow is
markedly lower in the setting of jq1
treatment followed by 199 treatment as
compared to all other treatment groups
as is the abundance of cd13 cd33
uh positive cells in the bone marrow and
this is basically a result that's
consistent with the idea
that this this sequential therapy of jq1
followed by 199
is leading to the apototic cell death
rather than a d
differentiation process in these amls
now this entire story as we were putting
it together was very interesting to us
for another reason and that is that it
hearkened very much to a separate study
that we had
published a couple of years ago in the
second melanoma
so in the upper left of this plot i
remind our of this slide i remind you of
the results that we have in
aml where we find that resistance to jq1
leads to hyperactivation of mick and
quan
and consequent sensitization to bcl2
family inhibitors
now in the upper right of this slide
what you see is a different finding
published in 2017 where we observed that
melanoma cells with activating b
ref mutations when treated chronically
with
um inhibitors of braf or braf mech
signaling
develop resistance that is on always in
our hands associated
with the hyper activation of mick as
read out by increased mick protein
levels and so what you can see here
for each cell line uh for example
starting with colo 679
we have mic levels in the parental cells
parental cells upon short-term treatment
with a raf inhibitor where mick is down
regulated
mick is after all a uh a target of the
map kinase pathway
um and then resistant cells that remain
under drug
selection pressure where in this setting
we always find
not only activation reactivation of mick
but really hyperactivation of mic
relative to parental cells
now what these two studies both
suggested to us um through through
separate and extensive studies that i'm
i'm going to gloss over here
is that although there are many
different resistance mechanisms
to bromodomain inhibitors in aml or to
braf inhibitors in melanoma
which i've shown here at the top of the
schematic and although these different
resistance mechanisms can be transduced
through different oncogenic signaling
pathways
they always seem to converge upon one
particularly
important event which is necessary and
sufficient for resistance and that is
the activation of me
of the mekonca gene now this is a
phenomenon that we refer to
as convergent resistance and this
phenomenon really got us thinking
uh similarly about the notion of
collateral sensitivity
the way that the way that it guided our
thinking was as follows we said look
if it's actually true that aml's and b
and and b ref driven melanomas um
always exist in just one of two states
either an initial drug naive state where
they're driven by
b raf in the setting of melanoma or brd4
in the setting of aml
or they can exist in a second state
which is a therapy resistant mic
driven state where they are no longer
dependent upon their initial drivers
but have become dependent upon mick for
survival
then that allows us to simplify our
thinking about resistance we no longer
have to think about many different
resistance mechanisms and alterations
instead we can just say hey these tumors
exist in one of two states
either in an either a state that's
driven by their initial oncogenic driver
or a straight state that's driven by mig
and that means that if we can come up
with therapies that specifically target
the mcdriven state
that those therapies might have
particular activity in the setting of
therapy resistance
now as you know i'm sure mick itself is
not
conventionally thought of as being
directly targetable with um
small molecules we hope that will change
in the future but right now that's
probably
where most people would agree that we
are however
um mick might be targetable there the
mick
active state might be targetable through
um
through synthetic lethality and so to
test that
we took drug-resistant aml cells and we
treated them with a panel of different
small molecule anti-cancer therapies
and we compared this the sensitivity of
the resistance cells which have
hyperactivated mick
to the sensitivity of their parental
counterparts what we found is there's
there's a set of drugs
that that are much more potent in the
setting of
hyperactivated mick than they are
in the parental in their in their
parental match parental counterparts
and this holds up across many different
aml cell lines
many of these drugs which have increased
activity in the setting of mick
activation
are inhibitors of the mitochondrial
apoptosis pathway
uh the inhibitor of mcl1 s63845
the inhibitor of bcl-2 abt-199 and
others
there are also notably drugs like bptes
an inhibitor of the glutamine pathway
which have been
previously described as synthetic lethal
targets of mic-driven tumors which was
notable to us
now in a very similar way you can do the
same thing in melanoma cells you can say
okay
if mick activation is a hallmark feature
of drug resistance
what are the drugs that make activated
melanomas would be sensitive to
and so we took a very comprehensive
approach to the exact same question
and what you're looking at here are a
series of different results that we had
so i want you to focus
first on the the plot under the words
glucose metabolism
so what we did here is we took many
different models of melanoma
the the models indicated by blue
marks are drug naive
melanoma cell lines which are expressive
and what you find is that those cell
lines are have modest sensitivity to
inhibition of glucose metabolism
in this case using the the drug to uh
2dg
by contrast if you take melanoma cells
and you make them resistant
to b ref inhibitors through any one of a
number of different approaches
either by evolving them to resistance by
constitutively activating pathway
resistance uh
resistance resistance pathways by
identifying
intrinsically resistant cell lines or by
over expressing mick
in all of these cases what happened what
what results
is mick hyper activation and consequence
sensitization
to this inhibitor of glucose metabolism
so what this essentially is saying that
is it's underscoring the idea
that many roads lead to resistance but
that resistance is
always characterized by make hyper
activation
and consequently uh is vulnerable to um
to to to drugs that are synthetic lethal
with activated mick
other examples of these synthetic
lethalities include glutamine metabolism
serine metabolism and sarc family kinase
signaling at least in the in vitro
setting
and again you know the reason why these
are interesting to us is they suggest
that they might that they might be
effective combination therapies and here
i'll just show one example of that
this is a long-term tumor progression
study where we're looking for cells to
develop resistance to a therapy
what you're seeing here is we're
plotting a tumor burden on the y-axis
versus time on the x-axis
as you can see if you treat with the
raph inhibitor alone which is shown in
blue
what you get is stasis followed by the
outgrowth of resistance that's uh
the same phenomenon that we see
clinically if you treat with a drug to
satin it but inhibitor of stark family
kinase signaling which happens to be
synthetic lethal with mick hyper
activation
you get very little of a therapeutic
effect initially because of course
melanoma cells are not particularly
sensitive to dysapnid however if you
combine the satinib
an agent which has a greatly enhanced
activity
in cells that are resistant to ref
inhibitors and you combine that up front
with a raf inhibitor
you're able to effectively block
resistance evolution
by essentially combining two drugs
which which in their combination select
against resistance evolution
that's seen in vitro and it's also seen
uh in vivo in this case using a
different synthetic lethal
drug the the brd inhibitor jq1
so these results have been very exciting
for our group
because again i think they point to the
idea that
although there are many roads that can
lead to resistance to any one therapy
that those roads often lead to the
convergent activation of specific
downstream resistance mechanisms like
mick
or convergence upon a particular
cellular state
and by defining what those states or
convergent mechanisms are
we might be able to define therapeutic
strategies that target them
and in so doing have the capacity to
block or specifically target
many different types of resistance so
on the heels of that excitement we've
we've been looking more broadly in our
group
for so-called conserved collateral
sensitivities
and one of the ways we've been doing
that is taking oncogene-driven cell
lines
which are initially sensitive to a
targeted therapy evolving them over the
course of months to resistance until
they're fully resistant to that therapy
and then taking those resistant
derivatives along with their parental
counterparts
and treating them with a diverse panel
of drugs targeting different cellular
processes
and looking for drugs that have specific
activity
in the setting of the resistant cells
relative to the parental cells and those
are the ones that we call collateral
sensitivities
now just to give you a very high level
snapshot view of our findings
what we find is that collateral
sensitivity is a very widespread
phenomenon
so if you look across cell lines derived
from many different cancer types
aml melanoma colorectal cancer head and
neck squamous cell carcinoma
lung cancer and so on where in each case
we've evolved these cells to resistance
to the appropriate cognate targeted
therapy based on whatever the driver is
in that particular
uh cell line what you see
is that the resistant cells that emerge
are oftentimes
collaterally sensitive to other drugs
and those are the blue dots you see
below each
on below the zero point on the on the
y-axis
so this gives us a lot of hope because
it suggests that the development of
resistance to
to any one anti-cancer drug in any one
cancer type
has the potential to give rise to all
kinds of new vulnerabilities in a tumor
that can be exploited um
and and and a lot of our work is now
focusing on what these are and how we
can exploit them
so in conclusion um i hope that i've
conveyed to you the idea that
um uh that the alterations that drive
resistance to
to cancer therapies give rise to
collateral sensitivities
um that resistance mechanisms although
diverse in nature
frequently converge onto common
downstream biological mechanisms
and that as a consequence resistant
cells even those driven by
different resistance mechanisms often
share common collateral sensitivities
and then by targeting these collateral
sensitivities it may be possible to
build drug therapies that select against
resistance
um and these are just um simple
schematics depicting the idea of
convergent resistance
and collateral sensitivity with that i
want to thank you for your attention
um i want to acknowledge the folks in my
research group
who did uh the the work that i've shown
today
the antagonistic pleotropy story in aml
was
led primarily by uh kevin lynn an md phd
student in the lab
and justine rudder an undergraduate who
became subsequently a technician in the
lab and is now on her way to
phd studies the pathway activation
screening work was um
led by colin marks in the lab as well as
folks like peter winter and grace
anderson on the crispr analog version of
that our work on
convergent resistance evolution in
melanoma was driven
primarily by katie singleton a former
postdoc in the lab
and lauren crawford a former graduate
student in the lab
our our work is made possible because of
the contributions of our collaborators
uh including alex poisson on our aml
work
uh uh cheyenne mukherjee and karen
jakowski on our melanoma work and david
sabatini on some of our screening work
um and of course is made possible by the
by the funding sources you see here
so with that thank you very much for
your attention
thank you dr wood for that outstanding
presentation
for additional informative presentations
please view our agenda on our events
page
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted
via email thank you again for your
participation